jeff bezos you made it you made it to
space
crazy correct so crazy uh
jeff i have to ask why did you shape
your spaceship like that
uh simple you know i gotta have the
biggest dick in space
i mean you guys should know better than
anyone you got to keep your dick fat
so yeah it's weird that you'd know that
yeah yeah
that's a deep cut are you are you a fan
i didn't jeff i didn't we didn't realize
you were a fan
yeah oh yeah i like to my advisors keep
me up to date on you know
all the cultural phenomenons and
whatnots
nice did they tell you that we make fun
of you like all the time
oh who doesn't it's fair enough
that's fair enough i'm just more blown
away that your advisors consider our
tiny fat dicks cultural phenomenons
seriously that's a [ __ ]
shout out to them dude so let me ask you
this
is it like a little bit annoying that
richard branson kind of beat you to the
punch
don't even say that name that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he didn't even go to space he didn't
even make it there he just flew around
his dingy little airplane
and you know he couldn't even get it up
himself they had a tome up there his
little hang glider
told like he was a triple a
you know branson you [ __ ]
tiny deck piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so jeff um what inspired this this
mission to space because i know you know
this the actual space race happened
a while ago and all of a sudden there's
this new space race amongst billionaires
did the original one inspire you guys or
no no all aldrin
and armstrong they were just glorified
hacks
you know it's um alan shepard
he's he's the hero here first man in
space
uh you know that's why i named my fatty
after him right
but you know plus armstrong and aldrin
they didn't they didn't
they weren't rich you know i'm i'm a
billionaire
i mean this is really something i'm
gonna make space smell like dior
it's fair fair good point yeah that's a
good point oh yeah space does kind of
stink
yeah it does it's weird it says like it
smells like brisket
yeah brisket and trash and
old satellites and stuff dead dogs that
russia sent up here back yeah yeah way
back yeah yeah yeah that's always the
worst people don't even know about all
like the random animals that different
countries have sent
up here yeah yeah someone sent up like a
bag of lizards it was crazy
yeah yeah it was my my lizard was in
there
oh god i saw an old monkey flying around
yeah yeah
you just take it or oh no he's dead you
know you're just
hanging on by a few threads but
yeah wild yeah okay but
even though you're gonna make space
smell like dior i mean you have to care
a little bit right like
you're kind of taking out nasa like
everybody loves nasa yeah
no not me my dream is to bankrupt nasa
oh because i mean you know what it
stands for right nasa what
not ever going to space again
wait isn't that nessa yeah who the [ __ ]
cares god damn it you've
been [ __ ] talking to branson haven't
you
it's not gonna matter no one's gonna
even remember nasa it's gonna end up
being some
[ __ ] stupid little logo on an urban
outfitters shirt
sorry okay sorry for asking i'm sorry
dude stop talking about man sorry man
my apologies sorry jeff jeff my man
you're looking
ripped these days what what's going on
with you thank you
well you know you can't be scrawny and
run a company it's scientifically
impossible
so you know that's why i gotta get
ripped
yeah but elon musk isn't ripped hell no
eon looks like a [ __ ] bag of milk
and branson branson [ __ ]
branson is just like a giant [ __ ]
turd with an accent
[ __ ] but not me i got this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you branson so
how were the muscles working in in your
dating life yeah
like it works for company life but how
about your dating life we know you're
single now are you
is it helping the ladies respond well to
the muscles yeah
you know i'm i'm on the dating apps uh
hinge and
tender and raya you're on raya
really wow yeah yeah you know me and
bill like to
hit the town every once in a while bill
bill
gale gates bill nye gates gates oh bill
gates
yeah that's the one right right you know
i like to see who can drink the most
me i can no i wouldn't expect i
am the king
[Laughter]
you don't play jeff you got to be number
one in everything that's right
don't you forget that branson
[Music]
who are you saying it doesn't matter
it's just casey watch it
okay in case you know when he's watching
he's got satellites everywhere
yeah [ __ ] little spy yeah
in case he brings his dumb little hang
glider plane up to
yeah don't get me started on that again
[ __ ]
all right jeff another question for you
why'd you pick a 18 year old
to go to space with you to drink his
blood for survival
and you know if we happen to crash land
on some deserted island i'm gonna
eat that little [ __ ] entitled brat
first i mean
whose father buys them a multi-million
dollar [ __ ] joy space ride
all i got from my father was three
hundred thousand dollars
which i turned into 300 billion by the
way
oh yeah since i've been up here i'm my
net worth has grown from 200 to 300
billion
wow that's impressive that's that's
impressive time does work a little
weirdly up here yeah yeah everything's
weird in space yeah
but it's definitely to my advantage yeah
come here more often i wish we got a
hundred billion when we came out
no seriously ours i think went down all
we got is this [ __ ] pencil sharpener
yeah
so now that your net worth has grown so
much
what are you gonna use that for raya
who's in my vast wealth of money
to ensure that i am the only man left
on the dating apps platform how would
how are you gonna do that money money
money buys everything i
i am the king of takeovers i know how to
squeeze out the competition
like no one else oh he's gonna clone
himself
and create other profiles oh so what
would you name them
like like beef jesus and just different
forms of your name
junior junior is just jeff
just jr or jeff bezos jr
probably both right you have enough
money to have both yeah well you know i
was thinking
if i just if i'm the only guy on there
then
the ladies don't have much of a choice
right yeah
so yeah that's a good point you can name
one jizz beefos
you could yeah or
beef jizzo's beef jizzos yeah sorry we
don't use it these are
these are fascinating ideas thank you
thank you thank you thank you
thank you wow you know if you ever if
there's ever
like anything like that yeah any like
idea guys like
we would love to whiteboard with you for
a little bit yeah okay yeah if i need
some
marketing ideas for something like
engineering ones
too we yeah we can hold our pee for
seven days straight we don't have to go
to the bathroom we can we don't take any
breaks we can keep working
really what do you drink it what we'll
do whatever just to keep working we know
how much you love productivity so
that i do that i do that's what may be
the man i am today yeah i grew amazon
from you know a [ __ ] little online
bookstore to
the mega conglomerate it is today
i did that i did that you hear that
branson
we should have never brought up branson
i know
it's gonna be [ __ ] awkward when he
crosses him like yeah he's our next
guest
yeah branson's coming up here oh well no
no
no he's coming here no no no no no no no
no no we'll make sure he doesn't we'll
make sure
so you got all this money man like
obviously you're you're
you're buying out every dude on raya you
got that unlocked but like what do you
do for fun like what's your free time
like
uh on the weekends you know i like to do
some jeeping
right around the mud jeeping yeah
jeeping that's like like driving your
jeep
yeah it's jeeping yeah jeeping
yeah jeeping yeah like driving your jeep
yeah it's jeeping cool
you've never heard that problem before
no i can coin words whenever i want
okay all right so i am the richest man
on this planet
if i want to make up a word i make up a
word and everyone's going to adopt it
and agree to it and not question it
what's another one fricking
that makes sense i think that exists
cali whack
cali wack yeah what's that that's when
you're a jerk in california
yeah i've heard the term before
yeah that's sick actually yeah kelly
wick yeah
damn caliwhackers.com yeah
i callie wack before i beamed up this
morning nice yeah
freshly drained it seems like
billionaires have strange relationships
with their fathers
do you think that's because they're
intimidated by you guys from birth good
question
yeah they're all small dick losers
damn cool so what was the most difficult
part
about building amazon like just from the
ground up
well yeah uh-huh what
what princeton [ __ ]
all right guys i gotta go nice to meet
you yeah
[ __ ] tell branson i'm on my way
damn he does not like that dude
seriously
i mean he's kind of like a he's kind of
like a turd with an accent
a little bit he could have at least
answered my [ __ ] question though
honestly it was a bad question it wasn't
a bad question it was kind of mid
shuttle
ask better questions before i
unsubscribe from you